[Musique]
la boîte à outils de notre mécano
démocratique s'est enrichi de 25 avril
2019 d'un nouvel outil la convention
citoyenne
après plusieurs mois de travail 150
citoyens tirés au sort ont adopté 149
propositions pour changer la société
cette assemblée citoyenne est confortée
dans sa légitimité par l'histoire la
plus ancienne d'athènes à montesquieu ou
rousseau elle est renforcée par le
sérieux et l'implication dans le travail
accompli que l'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec les propositions
elle ne se substitue pas aux organes de
notre démocratie parlementaire mais
contribue à nourrir leur réflexion et
éventuellement leurs actions certaines
mesures intéressantes met en exergue des
actions déjà engagées
d'autres portent un espoir qu'il faudra
traduire en actes adapté à la réalité
notre société ces travaux ne couvre
évidemment pas tous les champs
nécessaires et utiles à l'évolution
écologique vers laquelle notre pays
s'est engagé des propositions même les
plus pertinentes aux solutions acceptée
par une majorité de nos concitoyens
supportable par des minorités actives ou
encore financer
il peut y avoir un chemin souvent
chaotique
je pense à la question des pesticides à
la politique énergétique ou encore aux
moyens alloués à l'innovation
tout ça n'est pas toujours aussi facile
que certains le croient
l'europe doit également être partie
intégrante de ces avancées d'une part
parce qu'elle pourrait être l'échelon le
plus efficace sur des dossiers tels
qu'une taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'union
comme la convention l'a identifié
d'autre part car elle s'est emparée du
sujet climatique avec un paquet vert
ambitieux qu'il va falloir maintenant
des gossier est agrémenté nous savons
tous que l'enjeu climatique et le défaut
de notre siècle
je suis persuadé que la solution est la
croissance décarbonés qui passe par
l'innovation
les nouvelles énergies et la recherche
et le développement madame la ministre
le gouvernement doit et va sûrement
écouter certaines propositions de la
convention
comment envisagez-vous d'intégrer ce
travail dans les stratégies
et engagements de la france pour remplir
nos engagements aux horizons 2030 et
2050 afin d'apporter une réponse durable
à ce défi global
merci la parole est à madame elisabeth
bornes ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire pour deux
minutes
le sénateur bignon effectivement la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
avait été lancé par le président de la
république suite au grand débat national
m'a remis ses propositions
dimanche dernier cette convention je
voudrais lui rappeler ce sont 150
citoyens tirés au sort
à l'image de notre pays des femmes des
hommes de 16 à 82 ans venant de tous les
territoires
ils ont travaillé avec beaucoup
d'exigence et d'engagement pendant neuf
mois et moi je voudrais d'abord le
rendre hommage l'aboutissement de cette
démarche c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
la démocratie et pour l'écologie et je
partage pleinement la vision de la
convention d'une transformation
écologique globale alors beaucoup de
propositions comme vous l'avez souligné
sont convergentes avec les orientations
que nous portons depuis le début du
quinquennat
d'autres vont créer du débat et c'est
normal le président de la république
avait demandé des propositions fortes à
la hauteur du défi climatique
le président les recevra va recevra des
représentants de la convention lundi
prochain et il pourra leur indiquer les
suites données à leurs propositions
certaines de ces propositions qui sont
finalisés ont vocation à être transmises
sans filtre au parlement voire à
référendum
cette étape est essentielle pour que la
démocratie délibérative s'articule avec
la démocratie représentative ou direct
d'autres propositions par ailleurs
doivent encore être approfondies
le président de la république l'a dit
nous devons penser une reconstruction
économique écologique et solidaire
les travaux de la convention sont au
coeur de ce projet merci
monsieur albéric de montgolfier pour le
groupe l'est républicain micro micro
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre devait démissionner mini chers
collègues le sénat a voté vous le savez
les deux premiers plfr parce que ces
deux plfr comportait des mesures de
soutien qui était efficace qui était
immédiate et en revanche il interroge
sur le troisième plfr même si on peut
regretter que les mesures réglementaires
n'était pas été prise à temps je pense à
la tva à 5,5 sur les tenues de
protection dont l'arrêté n'est toujours
pas pris mais un article d'un célèbre
journal satirique du mercredi va sans
doute incité ce texte à sortir dans la
semaine
comme quoi mais je voudrais vous parler
des du prochain plfr qui constitue c'est
vrai une déception puisqu'il ne comporte
aucune mesure de relance
aucune mesure de relance alors que notre
pays connaît une chute de son pib de
plus de 11%
et si on se compare notamment à
l'allemagne l'allemagne a décidé des
mesures de relance vous l'avez vu à plus
de 50 milliards d'euros dont 9 milliards
pour l'hydrogène ce qui représente un
investissement de plus de 5 5% du pib
nous en sommes à 2 5% en france et se
paie ce plfr ne comporte notamment
aucune mesure pour relancer
l'investissement des entreprises
investissement qui a chuté de 20 à 25%
il ne comporte aucune mesure sur la
consommation des ménages
à part c'est vrai l'automobile il ne
comporte aucune mesure pour inciter les
collectivités à investir et je pense en
particulier aux retards pris dans les
cpe heures au retard pris dans le très
haut débit qui ont des besoins
considérables et il ne comporte en effet
aucune mesure sur l'épargné des ménages
100 milliards d'euros d'épargné qui ont
été confinés qui devraient être des
confiné qui pourrait servir à investir
ou à consommer donc que nous sommes
nombreux au sénat a porté les uns et les
autres des mesures de relance dès
maintenant et j'ai moi même proposé des
mesures fortes si nous attendons comme
peut-être le grand dans le prévoit le
plf
le budget pour 2021 cela risque d'être
trop tard nous serons en quelque sorte
perdu six mois six mois par lequel nous
connaîtrons des défaillances
d'entreprises ma question est donc très
simple
pourquoi attendre pourquoi attendre pour
adopter des mesures de relance
indispensable merci madame agnès madame
agnès panière une hache est secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances pour répondre pour deux
minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur albéric de montgolfier
vous avez raison cette crise allait
inédite on prévoit une baisse de notre
produit intérieur brut de 11 %
et comme vous le savez très rapidement
et vous le salut est d'ailleurs des
mesures d'urgence ont été prises quatre
mesures d'urgence qui ont permis de
venir au secours de notre économie
très rapidement je veux dire ici plutôt
plus rapidement que beaucoup de pays
européens je pense aux prêts garantis
par l'état par exemple ont été
disponibles
quelques jours après leur vote dans cet
hémicycle
je pense également au chômage partiel au
report de cotisations sociales et
fiscales est évidemment au fonds de
solidarité qui a été au rendez vous pour
les indépendants ces plans de soutien
ils sont aujourd'hui complète ses plans
de secours sont aujourd'hui complétée
par des plans de soutien et d'urgence
sectorielle car l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est de stabiliser notre économie et
c'est ce que nous faisons nous le
stabilisons avec 14 milliards d'euros de
financement n'est pas tout à fait
l'épaisseur du trait qui compléteront
les efforts déjà déployés pour porter à
18 milliards d'euros le plan pour le
tourisme 10 milliards d'euros le plan
automobile effectivement avec un soutien
à l'électrification de notre flotte 15
milliards d'euros le plan aéronautique
qui porte un soutien r&d pour le futur
puisqu'il s'agit d'investir dans l'avion
décarbonés ou un milliard d'euros dans
la tête 400 millions d'euros pour la
culture autant de mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires pour accompagner
les entreprises
ils sont également complété par des
mesures transversales je pense au
remboursement anticipé de créances de
report en arrière des déficits ou de
primes à l'embauché exceptionnelle pour
les apprentis qui sont autant de mesures
extrêmement attendu par les entreprises
et par les jeunes ce plan sera prolongée
par un plan de relance vous l'avez dit
ce plan de relance nous y travaillons il
visera à accompagner la transformation
de notre économie
cette transformation nous en avons déjà
les éléments nous avons déjà
des crédits d'ailleurs disponible le sur
amortissement fiscal c'est un élément de
transformation rassurez vous nous ne
manquons pas aujourd'hui de carburant
pour avancer mais pour faire ce plan de
relance il faut stabiliser l'économie
avoir une vision sur l'économie mondiale
et nous serons au rendez vous dès
septembre merci fr 4 en 2015 ministre
macro prométhée la sauvegarde de tous
les emplois lors du rachat du français
alcatel par le finlandais nokia
cinq ans plus tard après déjà trois
plans de licenciements nokia perd 6
appliquer ce modèle de destructions
d'emplois avec la suppression de 1200 33
postes en france dont 400 sur le site de
lannion
dans mon département des côtes d'armor
l'insistance des licenciements
impacterait le service de recherche et
développement qui travaille pourtant à
l'arrivée de la 5g et de la
cybersécurité
dois-je vous rappeler que ce groupe
touche actuellement entre 65 et 80
millions d'euros du crédit impôt
recherche qui financent 30% des 2500
salariés de ce même service
cette trahison des salariés ressenti
comme cela n'a pour seul objectif que
l'augmentation des rémunérations des
actionnaires et des hauts dirigeants du
groupe
tout cela sous le matelas bien
confortable des subventions publiques
dont le cas s'est gavé pouvons nous le
dira c'est tout simplement le sens des
éternels licenciements boursiers
les sites de lannion et de nozay
également dans le sol dans l'essonne
participe pleinement à la réussite du
groupe avec des compétences
indispensables pour notre pays dans la
maîtrise de nos réseaux de
télécommunication votre simple demande à
nokia de revoir sa copie ne suffit pas
quand le gouvernement s'engagera-t-il
totalement en faveur de l'emploi de la
recherche et de l'industrie en
interdisant les licenciements boursiers
comment vous pouvez
vous sauvegardez une souveraineté
industrielle
je remercie la parole est à madame agnès
pannier à une hache et secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie et des
finances merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice bruno nokia a
effectivement annoncé un plan de
réductions très important de sa
recherche et développement en france
cette recherche et de développement et
n'est d'ailleurs pas uniquement orientée
vers la 5g mais elle couvre cet élément
là et c'est vrai que le retard pris
peut-être un peu léger par la france sur
cette dimension est potentiellement un
des éléments auxquels nous devons être
particulièrement vigilants pour éviter
ce genre d' annonce et je vous confirme
et je serai très directe que nous avons
demandé à nokia de revoir l'ampleur de
ce plan est d'accompagner de minimiser
le nombre de départs volontaires mais
permettez moi de vous dire que ça fait
cinq ans que nous sommes aux côtés des
salariés pour les accompagner pour faire
en sorte que la france est l'un des
seuls pays voire le seul pays à avoir
été protégés contre des restructurations
dans cette entreprise
et ça c'est un fait autre fait également
nokia a permis de sauver alcatel qui
était malheureusement et c'était il ya
quelques années dans une situation bien
difficile vous le savez comme moi dans
une situation qui a conduit d'ailleurs à
faire ce rapprochement qui était
malheureusement la seule façon de sauver
des emplois en france
sauver cet acteur européen qui est
aujourd'hui confronté à une concurrence
très importante d'un autre acteur opéra
ericsson que nous accueillons et pour
lequel nous allons essayer de monter
dans les prochaines semaines un centre
de r&d également donc il ya aussi du
positif dans ce secteur mais également
huawei qui est très accompagné par son
gouvernement
donc nous allons agir aux côtés des
salariés
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la manoeuvre
nous avons reçu hier les organisations
syndicales et nous pousseront au tien
juste dans leurs retranchements pour
obtenir les meilleures garanties pour
les salariés pour notre recherche et
pour notre souveraineté
merci la parole est à monsieur jérôme
durain pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
c'était en 2017 emmanuel macron avait
réussi à ringardiser les parties mon
parti le vôtre à celui de l'époque
monsieur le premier ministre en
brocardant leur incapacité à accepter ce
qu'ils venaient du camp d'en face
systématiquement aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron fait la même chose
regardons ce qui se passe c'est un crime
des costils les sénatrices et sénateurs
socialistes ont proposé l'année dernière
un texte équilibré et applicables qui
visait à lutter contre l'impunité pour
les crimes les plus graves et à répondre
à une attente de la société la réponse a
été c'est une bonne idée et c'est non
les députés socialistes ont repris cette
notion d'éco side avec une version un
peu différente dans leur a dit c'est non
cette fois c'est la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui dit l'écocide est
utile dans une version de plus
exigeantes d'être plus audacieuses
qu'allez-vous en faire monsieur le
premier ministre il ya peut-être un
risque à ne pas écouter les demandes qui
remonte de la société on peut parfois
même sentir une forme de mépris de
frustration alors nous ne sommes
parlementaires d'opposition on y est
habitué mais attention à ce que la
société elle n'y prenne n'en prennent
pas ombrage
alors il ya l'écocide il y à l'iesf leur
établissement c'est non le référendum
sur la dette des pays
c'est non une commission d' enquête sur
les colis 19 c'est non c'est parce que
pavlovien chez le premier ministre vous
allez écouter la société à défaut
d'écouter les parlementaires
qu'allez vous faire de l'éco side
qu'allez-vous faire des conclusions de
la commission consultative des citoyens
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le président mesdames et c'est
un triste messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur du rhin si
précisément cette convention citoyenne a
été mise en place à l'initiative du
président de la république c'est parce
que nous souhaitions nous souhaitons
écouter ce que les 150 citoyens tirés au
sort avait à nous dire sur le sujet qui
a été traitée nous souhaitions les
écouter et nous l'avons fait puisque
madame elisabeth borgne a reçu cent
quarante neuf propositions qui ont été
étudiés parmi celles ci vous le dites
vous le soulignez celle de l'écocide les
difficultés que j'avais eu l'occasion de
relever devant vous à propos de cette
notion d'éco side au printemps 2010 9,1
en décembre dernier à l'assemblée
nationale ces difficultés la demeure
elles sont de deux ordres d'une part on
ne peut pas soumettre cette proposition
au référendum puisqu'elle porte sur la
législation pénale qui ne fait pas
partie du champ de l'article rue du
champ de l'article non ça c'est d'un
point de vue procédural et au fond il y
a également une exigence dans notre
constitution je suis sûr que vous la
partagez
c'est l'exigence de précision de la loi
pénale or si je lis et vous avez vous
même dit que c'était peut-être une
écriture audacieuse si je lis ce qu'a
écrit la convention citoyenne
elles partent elles parlent de la
définition du crime déco side dans des
limites qui sont les limites planétaires
et
elle évoque le dépassement des limites
planétaires
je ne suis pas tout à fait certaine que
cette notion-là correspondent à
l'exigence de précision de la loi pénale
qui figure dans notre constitution pour
autant pour autant monsieur le sénateur
la question qui est posée celle de
l'atteinte à l'environnement est une
vraie question est devant vous j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire avec ma collègue
et isabelle borne à propos du texte sur
le parquet européen texte dans lequel
nous avons institué des juridictions
pour l'environnement et une nouvelle
procédure la convention judiciaire pour
l'environnement dans ce cadre là j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que nous étions
prêtes à réfléchir à un délit plus
générale de pollution des eaux des sols
de l'air qui pourrait trouver place dans
notre droit pénal de l'environnement
c'est donc sur l'incitation de la
convention judiciaire d'un pardon de la
convention citoyenne pardon c'est sur la
vocation de la lambada des doyennes que
nous pourrons réfléchir ensemble à ces
éléments là nous croyons beaucoup
évidemment à toutes les propositions qui
lui font de lapin faut vraiment conclure
madame la ministre nous les soumettrons
évidemment parlement merci monsieur
jérôme durain il vous reste 32 secondes
de répliques
même la ministre je vous parle
d'exigence démocratique vous parler
d'exigence de précision de la loi pénale
dominique rousseau dans le monde d'hier
dit pour des confiner la france
politiquement il faut reconnaître la
compétence des citoyens emmanuel macron
lui-même j'ai mes sources dit j'ai
besoin que vous sachiez prendre des
options forte même radicale sinon il y
aura le filtre de ceux qui les mettront
en musique
attention à ne pas trop filtré on peut
finir par faire déborder
la parole est à monsieur christian
cambon pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci veut merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères chers collègues depuis des
mois la turquie mène une politique de
puissance en méditerranée orientale et
multiplie les provocations alternant
démonstration de force et intervention
militaire
après les forages gaziers dans les eaux
territoriales chypriotes au mépris du
droit international
il ya eu l'offensive turque que contre
nos alliés de kurdes qui luttent
pourtant à nos côtés face à l'état
islamique puis le chantage aux flux
migratoires
les incursions en syrie en irak en libye
et j'en passe et voilà donc la turquie
vient d'agresser maintenant la frégate
française courbet qui menait une mission
de surveillance de l'embargo des armes
au large de la libye pour le compte de
l'otan ciblée à trois reprises par les
radars de conduite de tir de missile
turc
notre bâtiment quelle humiliation a dû
se retirer pour éviter l' escalade de la
violence
voilà où nous en sommes arrivés voilà où
nous en sommes arrivés au sein même de
l'otan le secrétaire général stoltenberg
parlant sans rire de désaccord entre
alliés et nos protestations ne
recueillant que huit soutien européen
sur les trente membres ce grave incident
jettent une lumière crue sur la
faiblesse diplomatique et militaire
d'une europe décidément incapable de se
faire respecter et qui ne sert plus qu'à
financer les reconstructions de pays en
guerre ou à exposer la vie de ses
soldats pour jouer encore un rôle sur la
scène internationale mais cet incident
après bien d'autres signes hélas aussi
la perte d' influence de la france dans
une région de la méditerranée où elle
fut autrefois si respectée et si écoutez
nous en reparlerons ce soir lors du
débat du au proche orient
concernant le proche orient alors
monsieur le ministre ma question est
bien simple
après les dénonciations et les
condamnations la france et l'europe vont
elles enfin agir avec fermeté pour
s'opposer à ce nouvel impérialisme turc
en d'autres termes allons nous passer de
la diplomatie des déclarations à la
diplomatie de l'action
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères pour
vous répondre
monsieur le président quand bon vous
étiez lundi soir à l'elysée lorsque le
président de la république recevait le
président sayed et vous avez pu entendre
les propos du président de la république
à l'égard de la turquie en disant en
particulier que la tire qui jouait un
rôle un jeu extrêmement dangereux et je
voudrais vous dire ici et dire au sénat
que la france estime indispensable que
l'union européenne ouvre très vite une
discussion de fond sans tabou sans
naïveté sur les perspectives de la
relation future de l'union européenne
avec ankara et que l'union européenne
défende fermement ses propres intérêts
car elle en a les moyens vous avez à cet
égard évoqué tout à l'heure la sphère de
la frégate courbet là tout est
absolument scandaleux réside dans le
fait que la frégate courbet participé à
un exercice de l'otan et que la frégate
turque il a interpellé elle couvrait une
violation de l'embargo sur les armes
décidé par les nations unies c'est un
acte grave que nous avons porté au sein
des instances de l'otan mais plus
largement il faut des clarifications
il faut des clarifications sur le rôle
que la turquie entend jouer en libye où
j'estime que nous assistons une
signalisation de la libye puisque
l'intervention militaire delà de la
turquie se fait par le soutien de
supplétifs aux syriens
cela veut dire aussi que il faut
s'interroger sur la manière dont on va
pouvoir pousser la turquie à aller à la
négociation dit 5 + 5
parce que ce le fait que la turquie
renforçant sap son poids en libye abouti
au fait que les ruses renforcent leur
une spécialisation croissante
ça veut dire aussi des explications sur
la méditerranée orientale sur le fait
que
il faut faire respecter le droit de la
mer le droit maritime internationale et
donc respecter les territoires de nos
propres alliés et des membres de l'union
européenne que son chypre et la grèce
cela veut dire aussi la même chose sur
l'énigme à conclure il faut au delà je
conclus au delà de la compréhension que
l'on peut avoir les garder la présence
de réfugiés en turquie on ne peut pas
accepter que les réfugiés servent de
moyen de pression et
d'instrumentalisation de la turquie à
notre égard donc ce débat doit denner si
merci de la question la parole est à
monsieur franck montaugé pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
monsieur le président cher collègue
madame la ministre du travail
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage a
été très dure à l'égard des français
pour lesquels le travail au delà du
besoin et de la nécessité est une valeur
centrale
le contexte économique et sociale
engendrée par la pandémie
la rend aujourd'hui inique et en réalité
complètement inadapté à la nécessité de
relance économique et à l'obligation de
solidarité nationale dans cette
situation comment entendez vous
concrètement revenir sur les principes
de votre réforme les mesures que vous
allez prendre doivent atténuer la crise
sociale et contribuer à la relance de la
demande intérieure du pays
le chômage va exploser pour tous ceux
qui seront confrontés retrouver un
emploi sera plus difficile qu'avant la
crise le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
français sera un facteur très important
de la relance de l'économie française
dans de nombreuses filières les chefs
d'entreprise compte sur la relance de la
demande intérieure pour restaurer leurs
citations d'entreprise l'économie marche
à la confiance
on le sait et un accompagnement
insuffisant de millions de chômeurs
empêchera en réalité le retour de cette
confiance indispensable prévoyez vous
madame la ministre de restaurer les
droits antérieurs à votre réforme est de
les améliorer
compte tenu de l'urgence économique et
social il a pris la parole est à madame
muriel pénicaud menace du travail
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur franck montaugé la crise
épidémique se prolonge en crise et que
micky sociale c'est pour ça que dans un
premier temps nous avons pris des
mesures immédiates dès le 14 avril par
un décret pour adapter la citation
l'assurance chômage au contexte du
confinement dans ce décret nous avons
permis le prolongement des droits
jusqu'au 31 mai nous avons prévu de
neutraliser la période de confinement
dans l'établissement et dans le calcul
des droits nous avons permis le cas de
démission légitime pour des salariés qui
auraient démissionné pour un autre
emploi qui se serait retrouvée juste
moment du confinement en incapacité de
prendre le nouvel emploi bref nous avons
pris toute une série de mesures pour
protéger immédiatement nos concitoyens
touchés de plein fouet par la le la
situation nouvelle inédite massive de
confinement vous m'interrogez sur la
suite lorsque nous avons fait la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui est
partiellement entre une application
pourquoi nous l'avons fait
d'abord pour tenir compte à la fois d'un
impératif de protection et aussi deux
incitations à l'emploi dans un contexte
est vrai il est vrai il ya quelques mois
nous le célébrions ensemble ou nous
avions réussi grâce à toutes les
réformes que nous faisons à faire
descendre le chômage de près de 10% à
8,1 pour cent et nous étions sur la voie
d'aller vers les 7 % le contexte
effectivement à changer mais nous avons
voulu aussi lutter contre l'extra
l'excès des contrats courts
beaucoup des parties de cette réforme
visait à amener plus de cdi et moins de
contrat extrêmement court nous avons
aussi protéger les indépendants qui est
maintenant une assurance chômage nous
avons mis en place des droits nouveaux
pour les démissionnaires qui voulait
créer leur entreprise
je ne crois pas que vous les supprimez
tout ça la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment avec
pragmatisme devons nous adapter un
certain nombre de choses par les
principes qui sont bons sur le long
terme mais à certaines de curseur à la
situation nouvelle
effectivement de crise de crise
économique et donc de risque sur
l'emploi dans le cadre de la
concertation avec les parties
sociaux que je mène sous l'égide à la
demande du président de république et d'
où les russes président de la république
les reçoit tous tout à l'heure nous
avons un sujet principal c'est la
mobilisation pour l'emploi il ya cinq
sujets à des sujets il faut bien sûr
nous en discutons mais ça ça se passe
par le dialogue social et avec
pragmatisme
monsieur franck montaugé vous avez
quarante et une secondes de répliques
merci madame la ministre vous vous ne
m'avez pas convaincu mais vous n'avez
surtout pas du tout parlé de formation
professionnelle et je le regrette parce
que c'est un point clé dans mon groupe
nous pensons que cette période difficile
doit être mise à profit pour former aux
métiers de demain que nécessite dans la
plupart des filières la transition de
modèles jusqu'à la sortie de crise
on pourrait imaginer que l'état finance
en quasi totalité les stages de fin
d'études et de pré embauche des jeunes
pour tous les niveaux de qualification
nécessaire
dans la même idée l'état pourrait aussi
accompagner les chômeurs en phase de
formation dans les filières nouvelles ou
en reconversion et on sait qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sont concernés et je
rajoute à cela
n'oubliez pas non plus madame les
contrats très court dans l'hôtellerie
l'événementiel le tourisme qui font
aussi l'économie une parle de l'économie
et de la vitalité de massino les
marchands de journaux font partie de
notre quotidien notre culture en
garantissant l'accès à près de 2000 titi
sont des vecteurs essentiels de la
culture et de l'information et des
acteurs essentiels de la proximité
plus précisément à travers les 23 1000
points de vente répartis sur l'ensemble
du territoire il assure un véritable
service public en garantissant la
diffusion et la pluralité d'une presse
indispensable à notre vie démocratique
mais après les 55 jours de confinement
qui ont mis à rude épreuve des
commerçants revenu généralement modestes
ils doivent désormais faire face à la
crise du secteur de la distribution de
la presse en effet entreprises
presstalis qui distribuait 75% de la
presse écrite sur l'ensemble du
territoire national est en faillite dans
la métropole de lyon et le rhône la
filiale régionale de presstalis a été
placée en liquidation judiciaire depuis
le 15 mai ainsi depuis plus de cinq
semaines les marchands de presse ne
peuvent plus vendre à leurs clients
nombre de journaux habituels notamment
les nationaux qui ne reçoivent plus dans
le même temps les loyers de ces
commerces ont cours
cette situation pénalise très lourdement
et 550 kg au delà
trop paul de lyon à la situation
économique déjà souvent fragiles et
génère une baisse du chiffre d'affaires
de l'ordre de 75% risquant de précipiter
la fermeture de nombre de maisons de
presse mais c'est le cas aussi à
marseille à toulon c'était le cas aussi
à nantes et dans de nombreuses autres
villes sans mauvais jeu de mots car la
situation ne s'y prête pas le temps
presse ces professionnels sont aux abois
car si l'an dernier 579 points de vente
ont fermé fin avril 740 ont déjà tiré le
rideau
il faut donc éviter que la situation
d'ores et déjà extrêmement préoccupante
pour le pluralisme de la presse ne vire
à l'hécatombe
aussi monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire rapidement pour
qu'une solution pérenne soit enfin
trouvée à cette crise de la distribution
de la presse
la parole est à monsieur franck riester
ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice guillemot comme vous
savez le gouvernement est très attaché à
suivre de très près l'avenir des
marchands de presse seuls ils
représentent un maillage très important
culturel et un maillage très important
d'information partout dans les
territoires
le gouvernement a pris la décision
d'assouplir dans la réforme louis michel
les conditions de gestion c'est ma
chambre presse pour leur donner des
meilleures conditions économiques
il a veillé à ce que à travers la crise
de presstalis il puisse toucher tous les
ducs qui leur était promis le
gouvernement veille aussi à ce que
malgré les difficultés de presstalis que
vous avez rappelé malgré le redressement
de presstalis au niveau du siège et de
bobigny de la liquidation des dépôts de
presse l'avenir de la distribution de
prêts soient garanties pour que
notamment les marchands de journaux
puisse continuer de vivre c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
soutient la reprise de presstalis au
haut niveau aux parisiens et aux niveaux
de bobigny par la coopérative des
quotidiens en investissant 80 millions
d'euros pour accompagner cette reprise
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ils
travaillent avec les problèmes les
dépositaires indépendant avec les
messageries lyonnaises de presse avec
les préfets de région pour trouver des
solutions dans les 15 dépôts qui doivent
être repris suite à la liquidation de
presstalis
[Musique]